[Música]
hace 15 años yo trabajo y me dedico
profesionalmente al desarrollo humano y
en los derechos humanos comencé fundando
el periódico y el proyecto del hormigón
armado que es un canal de solidaridad
para la gente y las personas que de
alguna u otra forma
nuestra sociedad ha empujado hacia sus
espacios más peligrosos a las calles
para ello hemos fundado un montón de
herramientas el periódico de los lustros
calzados proyectos en salud becas
educación
y hemos logrados significantes cambios
hemos trabajado más que todo para la
población que vive yo trabaja en las
calles y principalmente enfocándonos en
los ilustres calzados que son personas
que en el uso de sus pasamontañas nos
denuncian una fuerte agresión y una
bueno la discriminación social uno de
los obstáculos fuertes que enfrenta la
población que está en contacto con la
calle que no representa esta población
son unos pocos de ellos que sin embargo
injustamente se por ello se discrimina y
estigmatiza a muchas otras personas es
el consumo de inhalantes o el vuelo
este es el por ejemplo por ello se
discrimina a muchos de los los tres
calzados injustamente el consumo de los
inhalantes el vuelo o el dinero la queja
son solventes que al ser aspirados de
una u otra forma cambia nuestra manera
de pensar y cambian como reacciona
nuestro cuerpo
al comienzo su efectos alucinógenos sin
embargo con el consumo rutinario el
alucinógeno va va quitándose mientras
cree la dependencia en nuestro cuerpo
hace muchos años un amigo que estaba
atravesando por esta situación me contó
sobre su primera experiencia con el
vuelo me la contó más o menos así él me
dijo yo era joven tenía unos 13 años y
ahora nuevito en esto de las calles y un
día yo estaba con mis amigos y bueno me
invitaron un poquito de vuelo yo me puse
todo corajudo lo agarré y lo puse contra
mi nariz y una ley
y me subió y bueno yo recuerdo otra vez
agarrar el trapo ponerlo contra mi
botellita o parla y otra vez poner el
trapo contra mi nariz y aspire y exhale
y aspire ya se sale y recuerdos a alejar
un poco la mis brazos de mi nariz y vi
que mi nariz se había salido de mi cara
que mi nariz estaba ahí en el trapo
y de repente vi como una mosca empezó a
volar mi nariz en frente de mí y yo me
desperté y salí y salí corriendo en
frente de mi nariz persiguiendo las
sobre las calles de la paz
y bueno al perseguirla joven y recuerdo
muy claramente que escuché en mis oídos
ese demonio ese demonio que vive en mi
botellita sin vuelo que me persigue hace
ya mucho tiempo y el demonio me dijo
aspira me
y deja que lleva entre entre tu cabeza y
entre tus cuerpo si entre tus huesos
aspira medio te daré calor vos solito y
conmigo te darás cariño
aspira me y deja que te quede calor que
te deje olvidar yo te quitaré tu hambre
yo te quitaré tus miedos yo te quitaré
tu frío
aspira me profundo pollicita y exhalar
ese cruel invierno que te sacude tu
esqueleto de que tarde tu hambre te
quitaré tu enorme sed que tienes de
cariño devolveré una estrella de fútbol
quiere ser mariposa nada más delicado y
nada más hermoso que tu vuelo sobre las
inmundas calles o quiere seguir siendo
polillita humilde oscuro camuflado niño
drogado casi invisible no las incómodas
mientras limpias sus parabrisas quieres
acaso despertarles
donde estaban en las borracheras de tus
padres donde estaban cuando esa noche tu
el miedo te protegió y te hizo escapar
para que no volvieras a tu casa jamás
donde estaban cuando tú y no gastes de
tu colchón de asfalto al que mojaste
llorando por tu hermanita por tu perrito
por tus amiguitos desde la escuela que
no volverás a ver jamás dónde estaban
cuando desgarraba sus brazos con tus
primeros tajos porque no hicieron
escándalo querido polillita quienes
acaso despertar almas recordarles que
aunque no seas un niño su hijo aún sigue
siendo su niño
y el polillita respondió y si me
regalaran una hamburguesa una frazada o
una madre quizás
hay retos enormes para el desarrollo de
las personas primero debemos cubrir las
necesidades básicas que tenemos la
necesidad de cubrir el hambre el frío el
cariño aquellas necesidades que ese niño
quiso cubrir inhalando vuelo es muy
demostrado que la desnutrición infantil
causa obstáculos en el desarrollo
durante toda la vida lo mismo es con la
violencia
si uno crece en un ambiente violento
desgasta la mente como un motor
constantemente a toda máquina pero luego
de eso están las necesidades del
espíritu y es aquí un poco donde yo
quiero enfocar mi charla del día de hoy
hace cuatro años
yo soy coordinador del programa nacional
de adolescentes de 6 the children es un
programa bien grande estamos trabajando
en 21 municipios en hogares de acogida
con adolescentes en conflicto con la ley
sobrevivientes de violencia situaciones
de pobreza un montón de situaciones es
un programa que hemos podido llegar a
ocho mil adolescentes hemos logrado
conseguir empleo digno para unos mil
jóvenes hemos creado 150 emprendimientos
que están dando medios
dignos para personas que quizás no
tendrían estas oportunidades esto me ha
permitido comprender de manera más
estratégica lo que es el desarrollo
humano en el área que yo conozco mejor
que es la juventud y la adolescencia
a mí me encanta trabajar con la
adolescencia
es ahí donde yo creo que se pueden hacer
unas transformaciones muy fuertes muy
profundas luego de la primera infancia
es en la adolescencia donde más se
desarrolla en nuestra mente ahí es donde
se siembra nuestra conciencia social es
el terreno más fértil para desarrollar
nuestras habilidades de la vida las
habilidades de vida que son la
comunicación son hitos del desarrollo
como el autocontrol el autoestima la
buena toma de decisiones son realmente
muy importante desarrollar estas
habilidades de vida cuán importante es
poder comunicarse bien si yo no habría
podido aprender desarrollar la habilidad
de comunicarme en la adolescencia no
sería bastante difícil estar aquí frente
a todos ustedes hablando creo que hay no
sé si en personas cuán importante es
para una persona trabaja atravesando una
situación difícil el tema de la
autoestima es muy fundamental es difícil
pero se puede trabajar y el trabajo
empieza aquí primero empezamos
trabajando con las personas para una
autoestima fuerte reforzar sobre las
personas su resiliencia
su amor propio su respeto propio y que
pueden generar planes de vida
conscientes y para salir adelante
obviamente cuando ya las personas se
quieren deben saber cuidarse lo segundo
que trabajamos es la salud sexual y
reproductiva y luego las personas deben
tener los medios para perseguir sus
aspiraciones deben tener un
empoderamiento económico fuerte tener
las oportunidades económicas dignas y
seguras para perseguir sus aspiraciones
el empoderamiento económico obviamente
desde debe trabajar de manera integral
con trabajar con la familia con la
sociedad y trabajar la movilización
comunitaria y más allá debemos trabajar
en el nivel institucional con las
instituciones con el aparato del estado
hacer una buena gestión pública que
realmente apoye al desarrollo de las
personas esa es la estrategia integral
creada por sellos the children en 20
años y que yo estoy convencido que tiene
un impacto muy fuerte en las personas
yo creo un poco en mi experiencia
personal más o menos siguiendo esa
situación comencé empoderando y
trabajando lo que era mi espíritu
emprendedor
y a partir de eso hace 15 años fundé el
proyecto del hormigón armado con un
grupo de amigos queríamos hacer un
periódico cultural y gente de escasos
recursos lo pueda vender para generar
mayores recursos ya 15 años después
hemos impreso el número 74 de nuestro
periódico hemos vendido más de 350 mil
copias hemos generado un cuarto de un
millón de dólares más o menos para los
lustros que lo venden hemos
diversificado a nuestra oferta tenemos
el tour de la paz de los guiados por los
track alzados tenemos una fábrica de
galletas que produce cinco mil kilos al
mes para el subsidio materno nacional
tenemos proyectos de salud hemos apoyado
en muchos muchos casos de salud muchos
debido a muerte hemos obtenemos un
proyecto de apoyo escolar apoyo de becas
hemos sacado muchas personas a nivel
técnico nivel superior que han sido
claves para romper ciclos
internacionales de pobreza el hormigón
armado es un proyecto de la fundación
art y culturas bolivianas y también es
una asociación con personería jurídica y
legalmente compuesta por unas 100
personas
ilustra calzados trabajadores en
situación de calle informales y sus
familias el hormigón armado no es un
proyecto de caridad es un proyecto de
desarrollo es un proyecto de solidaridad
existe una gran diferencia la diferencia
es que la solidaria la caridad viene de
arriba para abajo la solidaridad es de
igual igual la diferencia es que
nosotros somos socios con las personas
que persiguen metas de vida sus propias
aspiraciones no son objetos de caridad
son sujetos de desarrollo son personas
que siguen sus propias aspiraciones con
respeto con dignidad con una propuesta
de integración social
sin embargo no fue fácil comenzar esto
yo me acuerdo hace unos 15 años cuando
teníamos nuestro primer número impreso
convocamos a mi casa a un grupo de unos
15 adolescentes jóvenes en situación de
calle y ahora joven y ahora hippie y era
muy idealista y ahora muy alegre y bueno
las personas que entraron a mi casa
contra estaban mucho con mi realidad y
con lo que yo imaginaba de niños en su
inocencia y su alegría entraron a mi
casa niños que yo veía como niños
ancianos demasiado vida a una corta edad
entraron desconfiados agresivos en
silencio había uno que estaba en un está
en un rincón que se estaba haciendo un
tajo en el brazo con un alambre y yo me
asusté mucho la verdad sinceramente y
dije en que yo no yo no soy trabajador
social yo no soy psicólogo yo no estoy
preparado para esto en que me estaba
metiendo
sin embargo bueno la vida nos enfrenta
bastante a esta situación esa infinita
crueldad que a veces nos distraen de ver
la infinita belleza que hay en la vida a
su mística y al altar que hay en cada
piedra con el hormigón armado empezamos
a trabajar con poblaciones que estaban
en una situación difícil creo que la
violencia el embarazo adolescente el
abandono son la punta de un iceberg
de una problemática muy compleja
realmente o salimos afuera ahí hay
personas hay mucha gente que está
viviendo conviviendo con la calle el que
muchos adolescentes y jóvenes consideren
a la calle más segura que sus propios
hogares es terrible es algo que no
podemos aceptar
es bueno cuando empecé con esta primera
experiencia con él con la población
participante empecé a conocer historias
bastante fuertes
historias terrible de violencia abandono
y empecé a ver un poco los agresores y
empecé a ver un poco a las personas como
víctimas de una violencia o esas
víctimas de una sociedad que les había
fallado y empecé a conocer eso me empecé
a deprimir me dio pena y bueno ya ver el
punto es que de haber seguido así yo no
estaría hoy aquí
y yo no habría durado mucho en este
trabajo lo principal lección y yo quiero
transmitir algo que fue muy importante
para mí fue un cambio de paradigma un
cambio de cómo ver a las personas que
están a trabajar atravesando situaciones
difíciles
yo no sé si el mundo es malo bueno yo
creo que el mundo tiene bastante de malo
tiene bastante de bueno hay mucha
inequidad lo que yo sí sé es que el
mundo es bien agresivo o es agresivo
para algunas personas es más agresiva
que para otras para personas en
situación de calle es despiadada a veces
los derrota
y si hemos enterrado algunos amigos que
los cargamos en el alma pero lo que yo
más he visto es gente
salir adelante he visto a gente que ante
situaciones extremas realmente
situaciones muy difíciles como han
podido salir adelante ahí es donde yo
realmente me di cuenta y empecé a
observar y empecé a tener un respeto muy
grande hacia el espíritu humano y su
resiliencia
vi que personas en situaciones complejas
de una u otra forma bien o mal
encontraban la manera de ganarse la vida
no sólo seguir adelante salir adelante
yo conozco varias personas que han
estado muchos años en situación de calle
ahora tienen sus familias están librando
una vida de bien realmente ante
situaciones muy muy adversas y es ahí
donde me di cuenta realmente esa
fortaleza del espíritu humano y eso eso
para mí fue clave para mi el desarrollo
no es sólo cómo se ven las personas a sí
mismas el tema de la autoestima sino es
cómo nos vemos a nosotros entre nosotros
para mí fue clave realmente entender y
admirar y respetar la fuerza del
espíritu humano
y bueno de esta forma allí entendí que
si yo lograba canalizar esta fuerza de
las personas es la resiliencia donde
sembraba podíamos cosechar ahí dejamos
de romantizar con algunos paliativos de
asistencialismo y demás porque claro
hemos cometido bastantes errores a tener
otro enfoque de trabajo un enfoque en
asocio con las personas para sacar
adelante sus propias aspiraciones y sus
sueños es ahí que pudimos nosotros
generar oportunidades que no fueron
fueron tomadas por todas las personas
pero sí por muchas personas
y así empezamos a trabajar el tema de
asocio y expandimos ese asocio empezamos
a involucrar a voluntarios a personas a
varias empresas que a veces se sienten
un poco confrontadas con esa situación
se sienten quizás como un david contra
goliat pero se unieron a esta causa
uniéndose pensando que tal vez no es una
causa que es por alguien que es mi hijo
pero todas estas personas son nuestro
niño y así el hormigón armado salió de
ser un pequeño emprendimiento a un medio
a través del cual muchas personas
pudieron sacar adelante sus propios
planes de vida y así nosotros también
nos volvimos a ser un canal para la
imprescindible importancia inspiración
que como dijo pitazo llega pero nos
debes encontrar trabajando y nos debe
encontrar trabajando bien
nos debe encontrar trabajando de manera
solidaria no de arriba para abajo de
igual igual no podemos seguir aceptando
a la calle como una situación terminal
para personas que viven en ella no
podemos seguir aceptando a la
reincidencia como norma para las
personas que entran salen entran y salen
de nuestras cárceles no podemos seguir
aceptando a los sistemas de protección a
los sistemas de justicia como los
principales agresores de las personas en
situación vulnerable o estas epidemia de
violencia que estamos viviendo como una
situación terminal
yo creo y estoy convencido que existen
hay muchas metodologías hay la capacidad
técnica para enfrentar esta problemática
yo les recomiendo que vean a muchas
instituciones yo tengo la dicha de
conocer a muchas personas muchas
instituciones que están haciendo
realmente muy bien su trabajo y lo hacen
con argumento lo hacen con respeto con
las personas y de igual a igual
mi mayor dicha lo que a mí más me gusta
es ver a gente salir adelante una de
esas personas es aquel joven que era
niño aquella ves que una vez se puso a
perseguir son a su nariz por las calles
de la paz
la historia que les conté al comienzo de
esta charla esa persona hace dos años y
medio se ha rehabilitado dejó la calle
dejó el consumo ahora está trabajando es
una buena persona es un buen amigo es un
buen padre y realmente lo ha hecho a
partir de un amor propio y ha salido
adelante como muchas otras personas las
que conozco yo quiero dedicar esta
presentación a mi hermana maría que con
esa fuerza con esa resiliencia que es lo
que clave que quiero resaltar aquí que
tenemos todas las personas con ese
espíritu de supervivencia y esa lucha
ahorita está luchando contra un cáncer
al cual estoy seguro que ya va a
derrotar les agradezco mucho y agradezco
también aquí a la presencia a los
directores de la asociación de ilustra
calzados del hormigón armado agradezco
mucho su atención y muchas gracias
[Aplausos]